we don't teach people how to lead it's a
skill it's a teachable learnable
practice we'll skill but we don't teach
people how to do it so they don't do it
why are we surprised that people don't
know how to lead it's not necessarily
because they're bad people so we didn't
show them how to do it
right if we didn't show somebody how to
how to how to be an accountant you
wouldn't give them your taxes because
nobody showed them they might be able to
do it and even if people are naturally
good leaders it's not natural that they
learned it from someone else
their parents or they had a really great
boss that they role modeled or maybe
they had a really bad boss they're like
I'm doing everything the opposite right
so they still learned it from somewhere
so we have to teach leadership we do a
very very bad job in the corporate world
of teaching people how to lead and as we
promote them we give them a one day off
site and we call them leaders
congratulations
nah man it's got to be regular and
ongoing and we have to build into their
incentive structures into their bonus
packages not just how much money they
make but how they treat people right it
was it was part of her question before
she's like you know we're trying to do
this growth revenue and also look after
our customers but the order of the
information is really really important I
talked about in the infinite game that
there are two currencies will and
resources in that order right I'll give
you two hypothetical examples
hypothetical example number one is a
seat by the way I've never met a CEO who
doesn't think their people are important
the problem is we're on the list
number one growth number two shareholder
value right number three our customer
and number four our employee see it's
one of my priorities number four right
there right
but the prop that is the problem the
problem is the order so here are the two
hypothetical examples CEO number one
says my number one priority is growth
and of course we care about our people
because without our people we'll never
be able to achieve our official goals
seeking number two number one priorities
are people that if we take care of any
bull I know we will meet and exceed all
our financial goals which company you
want to work for it's easy and human
beings are funny we can't help ourselves
we have a tell which is we speak in the
order we tend to speak in the order of
our own priorities so when you hear
somebody go you know guys we have to be
preoccupied with grow
from the revenue of course of course we
could take care of our people go read
the press releases when Mike Duke Mike
Duke took over Walmart he talked about
growth our people and then you go read
the same press release from Doug
McMillon he talked about our people and
growth go read the press release when
when when Satya took over he talked
about our people first he talked about
human beings first this matters right
and this is one of the things that we're
suffering in the in the world today
which is most of the standard business
practices that we use today or actually
leftovers from the 80s and 90s a man by
the name of Milton Friedman an economist
from the 1970s theorized the
responsibilities of business and he
wrote that the responsibilities of
business is to maximize profits within
the bounds of the rules within the
bounds of the law right what about
ethics like we've all seen companies do
very very very uncomfortable things and
they get dragged out in front of
government and they all say the same
thing we did nothing illegal completely
within our rights yet that doesn't make
it right just cuz it was legal right
there's something called ethics right
when a pharmaceutical company raises the
price of a drug that people need to
survive five hundred six hundred seven
hundred percent there's nothing illegal
about that but it's really unethical
right and the problem is is the 1970s
that theory - a new new group of
investors was really appealing and so
they started experimenting with new ways
of doing business based on that
definition and in during the 80s and 90s
we started to see that become really
really popular so the concept of using
mass layoffs on an annualized basis to
balance the books did not exist prior to
the 1980s and people like Jack Welch /
GE started practicing it and it started
to gain acceptance and now it's normal
we've either been subjected to layoffs
our company has used those layoffs or
we've lost a friend or a family to life
a friend of a family has been subjected
to us all of us right one degree of
freedom if not zero degrees of freedom
right of separation I mean rank and yank
where we rank people's a contribution to
stock price or revenue
the top 10% get promoted the double
bottom 10% get fired that's when the 80s
and 90s right the obsession with
shareholder value and shareholder
supremacy where we prioritize on the
once and needs desires of an external
constituency over our own customers and
over our own employees that's like
asking the coach who's trying to build a
good team what the fans want rather than
what the players need but that's the
standard of business today right and so
the problem is is we need to reject that
it was great for the 80s and 90s it was
great for these boom years where
everybody made money it no longer works
what got us here will not get us there
we have to abandon the practices of Jack
Welch and Milton Friedman of the 80s and
90s and we need to do it our way for the
modern day to your point we need to
build empathetic leaders we need to
build leaders who understand that their
responsibility is a human job we don't
sit behind desks and lead a company from
spreadsheets we cannot because as we've
seen it creates discontent inside our
companies there's no such thing as
loyalty anymore there's no such thing as
a gold watch at the end of your career
doesn't exist anymore there's an entire
group of people in this room who are too
young that when I say the world go gold
watch they don't even know what I'm
talking about right he has no idea what
I'm talking used to be a time that
you've worked for 40 years form company
and they gave you a gold watch the point
is is there's an opportunity to change
it and the opportunity is ours the
opportunity is ours
[Music]
[Music]